I don't know if you've been
following the events in, uh,
in France the last couple of days.
Uh, you know, by the way, you can,
those of you who know French,
you can get a TFR at foster.
Do I prefer strongly the ladder, uh, on
your computers? If you want to follow it,
just go to, uh, Google, uh,
ply affair or just go to Google and type
in [inaudible] or type in Kf and you
can get the news from a one o'clock
that is a treasure or from a,
you know, from eight o'clock at night.
And, uh, my other two universities,
a wall and Leon do completely shut
down I and Hannah and tour and,
um, uh, to loser, uh,
because this is a law that was going
to come into effect called the Loa pet
Cresa after the person who proposed it.
And what is this going to do?
Is it's going to, among other things, uh,
it's going to make the book the budgets
of each university kind of independent.
It's an attempt to, this is
a logical transition, uh,
into our topic today to Americanize
a French universities. Uh,
so that in a way, the result of which the
students don't like it, you'll have a,
you already have sort
of a gap between the,
the really good universities like
[inaudible], uh, or Leon do. Uh,
and the ones that are disservice, struggle
along, uh, many of the new ones, like a,
the product Calais a that a friend of
mine actually, you know, set up. And,
and when he was in the ministry, I, and
I'm in the little ones, like a Shamba,
he and Beth and I saw and
all the others. And, um,
because of the conditions that are so
difficult in, in, in French universities,
which are woefully
understaffed and, and uh, uh,
the ones that were built in the
early sixties and early seventies,
like the infamous Lieutenant
Vinita News and which is a,
we're going to talk once was puppy.
Uh, I think it's by, he got to have,
and they know the conditions
are just a very, very dreadful.
So there's been a lot of,
uh, of opposition there.
And then now the Sarcozi is
president, uh, that, uh, the,
the police, there was these
entrepreneurial moose clay
or kind of a really, uh,
a brutal, um, um,
interventions by the crs a yesterday
and a couple people heard it don't care.
Uh, we're 1968 began, uh, and
in hand I think knowing tour,
uh, uh, rather, uh, so, uh,
this matter of fact when I was
teaching in a role, I do, uh,
I do a course, I've done the
last couple of maize of course,
of a couple of weeks there. And, uh,
the first day it was just only met my
students and we went to a demonstration
against Sarcozi, you know, in
front of the Palace of Justice.
And we were out numbered by the crs, but,
uh, and they took photos of all of us.
And I think that one of the things that's
going to happen in the future is that
a, you know, this is going to
be a very, um, very tense time.
I think now that the big strikes in
Paris now of course, which you know,
come Debbie too would like all the time
I've taken out the train's about uh,
oh one out of a about 15% of the
trains are running and the whole line,
if you know Paris, the whole metro,
the rer, the whole line bay, uh,
Bay,
which goes from a several the shoulders
all the way to two YC to the airport,
I just completely shut down. And, um,
the buses are about trying to get
about 10%. And so it's just chaos.
And I remember when everybody was on
strike when I was teaching Leon, you know,
I take the train, the trains
were on strike with the
buses forward and I took it,
I take the train up to Leo to, uh, from
where we live or from near where we live.
And, and I have to walk the
block, which is where Leon do is.
And that's about five miles or six miles.
And I mean,
it's not in the long run or one walk,
but people are very inconvenienced.
And the other thing that's going on
and the reason that the railroad, uh,
railroads are out had nothing
to do with the pet krass law.
It has to do with the fact that a
Socrates attempt to, um, to Americanize,
um, uh, France, uh, you know,
it involves sort of
withdrawing a rights that,
that certain categories of
workers, uh, received. And, uh,
there's a lot of anger now in Paris and
one other cities too against the strikes.
And most people in France do
not approve of the strikes. Uh,
and sometimes they do, sometimes
they don't. I'll give you an example.
People that work in the meats whole who
are underground, you know, the, the,
the drivers of the Metros, they're
underground all the time. I mean,
imagine working eight hours a day and
you're underground the whole time. Uh,
they have the right in principle is,
is it 50,
does everyone remember
if it's 50 or a dying?
Do you remember if it's 50 or 55
for the, they show photo, the, uh,
[inaudible] 55, but there's some
of that to the TJ drivers. Uh, uh,
and that's a big, high, high
stress occupation. I mean,
it's not like driving a plane, but
you don't drive a plane. I don't know,
you pilot a plane, but, uh, I, you know,
they can have the right to, to, to, uh,
retire at 50. Now, that
seems awfully young.
And in Sarcozi in his campaign,
uh,
against the ill fated campaign of Sega
Lend Royale Royale said that he wanted to
make the French work again. He also
said a lot of other provocative things,
and for son of immigrants,
a Fisa, these Amy, hey, who
seems to hate immigrants, uh,
a very provocative, um, provocative
things, but, but anyway,
he's going to carry these policies,
uh, uh, you know, until the,
until the very end. And so this, this is
going to happen, you know, quite a lot.
I've got a suit to nos to test
a thesis defensively on a jury.
I have to dissipate in
and, uh, in December.
And I'm kind of wondering whether you
know, whether this is going to take place,
but, but, uh, uh, you can follow
this through the newspapers
and, and, uh, through, um,
uh,
the other thing if you,
if you read French and one where you
can follow it through the New York Times
online or anything, uh, but you can
also get the [inaudible] affair. Uh,
so you can read Lee Bay every day or
you can read a pneumonia or whatever.
If you want to keep up on this. I'm going
to be this afternoon calling my, uh,
student, uh, uh, pals in, in,
in raw and finding out
what's going on with them.
One of them who's always in every
demonstration, he's always there.
And it's the last time he went out to
demonstration all these police and they
know him because he's in
all the demonstrations. And
this one policeman said to,
we've got this huge, you'll stick and
is this the students is a little teeny,
teeny guy and he has a stick. And he
says, uh, I, I'm reserving this for you,
spend and all of this. And uh,
they have a memory too. But anyway,
so a sub regional phones a month and on.
Why I want to talk though that that is,
I think, a logical thing to talk about
because I'm going to talk, uh, about, uh,
about anti Americanism, uh, in
France. It's hard to do that,
to talk about anti Americanism from
1945, uh, until now, uh, in a mirror,
um, uh, 50 minutes. And, um, uh,
let me see at the outset that,
uh,
having spent half of my life or half
of the last 30 years of my life and in
France, uh, uh, more than that actually,
I've never once encountered
anti-americanism, uh, which, you know,
something I went back, it doesn't
matter. But, but what it does,
what I am saying is that the,
that the Anti Americanism and France has
always been against the United States
policies. And, uh, particularly
the earlier days, uh,
United States that were
cultural imperialism, uh, but
his head, nothing to do with,
you know, anti-americanism
against, uh, against, uh,
American people.
I've been introduced in a book,
which I contribute some sort of random
musings about living in l dash uh, as a,
as a political refugee, uh, in
France, uh, at various times. Uh,
and, uh, people joke about that.
Uh, but, uh, so I'm differentiating,
you know, anti-americanism
like people that they don't
like Americans or, uh, with,
uh,
anti a US policies in an anti what
was considered by many people,
particularly intellectual server,
uh, cultural arrogance that, that,
that,
that risks making France less
than what it had always been.
Uh, and so let me talk a little bit about
that. And here I'm drawing a heavily,
at the first part of the lecture
on my friend Dick is, uh,
a book on anti-americanism
in the early stages.
But it's an interesting story
and it's one that's worth,
that's worth a telling now to,
uh,
you know, when, when, um, when our
teaching role, I go to often to this cafe,
this near the railroad station there,
and it's the cafe where we're Saska, uh,
and Simone de Beauvoir who are well known
to almost everybody used to go all the
time. And it's kind of fun
to be in a cafe where, uh,
where you imagine that they
were, um, and you know,
they were good example of kind of the
intellectual anti anti anti-americanism
that emerged after World War Two.
Um,
now why did this kind of a philosophical
and intellectual anti-americanism a
merge?
Uh,
you have to put it in the context of the
ideological controversies that emerged
out of world war one a. And
by that I mean from, you know,
1945, uh, well into the mid, uh, 1950s,
uh, they were doc strikes against
the arrival of, of us, uh,
military equipment. Remember
the Americans had, um, huge,
huge basis, uh, in France
until the time of the goal.
If you go to the town of Chateaux who, uh,
which isn't a very interesting town, uh,
and the only great restaurant
in it left to move to tour, uh,
I used go buy these just
abandoned airfield. It used
to just be full of American,
uh, um, uh,
military air force equipment
and uh, and uh, and officers.
And so you see a lot of these,
um, uh, a lot of these signs,
there were angry outbursts even
against the Marshall Plan, uh,
in the Marshall Plan is, as you
know, from other courses abroad, uh,
American aid in great quantities to,
uh, to western Europe. Uh, you know,
one of the reasons was to keep the
western Europe out of, out of Soviet,
uh, influence. Um,
and this drew a predictable attacks from
the pouty [inaudible] different from
the Communist Party, uh,
uh, because of the, of the,
the obvious ideological, uh, uh,
division that was, that
was the Cold War. Um, so,
and it also was a time when the
Rosenbergs in this country were executed,
uh, uh, for allegedly passing
nuclear secrets to, uh,
to Soviet agents and,
and these kinds of executions as has
been the execution of [inaudible], uh,
who were anarchists who were executed
in 18, 27. Uh, you know, the,
these have with the mass press, uh,
all the way before Internet, uh,
great ramifications. Um, but you know, Eh,
the French economy grows so
rapidly over the next 30 year,
the 30 glorious years.
Um, and part of, of,
of the, the rise of consumerism and
a consumer culture, uh, in France,
it was backed by the
arrival of such novelty.
There's refrigerators and things like
that was very much identified with u s
culture and was a debated,
uh,
a particularly by intellectuals,
uh, rather, um, uh,
rather heatedly. Uh, there were
pro American intellectuals, uh,
who made the case in the very beginning
that the, that the American path, uh, was,
uh, uh, the way to go. Uh, uh,
the most famous was probably
about, oh, hey, well, uh,
Oh, a, a r o. N. But there were
others like Francois Mohair Yak,
and I can't remember if chips in his book
I mentioned he has, I'm sure he does,
but the communist intellectuals were
adamantly against all things, uh,
that were American. And of course, they
were very much over the top. Um, uh,
Dick Kaiser will, uh, uh, quotes, uh,
uh, the famous communist poet there,
Louie [inaudible] gone, uh, uh,
describing the u s as quote,
a civilization of bathtubs
and Frigidaire's, uh,
in 1951,
as if this was a very bad saying.
And he did not meant it. As
Kyle says, as a compliment.
It was the party Communist, the
Communist Party, that coined phrase.
It's like the coca colonization of France.
And the arrival of Coca
Cola in France is of course,
was a terribly important moment. More
about that. Um, uh, in a minute, uh,
at the time of the natal pack, the North
Atlantic Treaty Organization in 1949,
these kinds of debates, uh, hit, uh,
hit a boiling point
and an age of graffiti.
The graffiti and the Yankee
go home, uh, was, uh,
was a bit everywhere.
Now the US nuclear capacity,
which was of course very soon
matched by, uh, the Soviet,
uh, nuclear capacity,
uh, seemed to raise, uh,
the cry, uh, can see Americans. Uh,
there was a sock on conference in
1950 against nuclear power, uh,
and in France, you
know, as a country that,
that it almost leads the
world in the percentage of,
of it's energy that is drawn from these
nuclear plants in which several, several,
or not all that far from us.
And a lot of,
there's a big sort of nuke
anti-nuclear, a reaction. Now that's,
that's mostly through eco ecologist and,
and the Greens and,
and folks like that. But,
um, in the beginning,
because the Americans are the ones
who had used the nuclear bomb. I mean,
other people have never
used a nuclear bomb.
Never since then have
used a nuclear problem.
We live in a world in which
Israel has a nuclear bomb,
which Pakistan has a nuclear bomb,
which India has a nuclear bomb as well as,
as France and Britain,
uh,
and s and China as well. I do
believe, uh, so therefore all this,
uh, um, it's still very
scary. But in the origins,
this anti Americanism was increased by,
uh,
by the fear that the Americans and their
cold war against the Soviet Union would
turn, uh, the damage will be not, not
be done in Mississippi or in Minnesota,
but will it be done,
uh, in, in Europe. Um,
and so intellectuals also accused,
uh, the Americans of ignoring,
uh, a European culture. Remember, uh,
the infamous Donald Rumsfeld,
uh,
refers scathingly too old
Europe at a time when, uh,
the Americans were invading Iraq as if
old Europe with its quaint streets and
old churches and, and long cultures
where something not worth, not worth,
uh, remembering. Um, but I,
again, I mean the, the, the,
the critique critiques of America,
the critics of American culture,
we're over the top, um,
uh, new [inaudible], uh,
the Communist newspaper and still today,
uh,
said that one could starve even if one
owned a telephone and the telephone,
uh, where you can't even find
a, a fixed phone anymore.
I can't telephone and I can't even
call on the phone when I go back to
University of Michigan because there are
literally only one fixed phone left on
the campus. And I don't have a cell phone
because I don't like to cell phones.
I can't stand them. I agree with
those people who said that, uh, uh,
that they had great faith in
humanity until the cell phone.
And plus my daughter's lost three of
them already. But, but, uh, um, uh, that,
that the French Minister of
communications in 19 four,
this is the French Minister
of communications in 1964.
Yeah. Of all who before you
existed, but not before I existed.
He called the telephone a gimmick in 19,
uh,
64. Uh, but it wasn't the telephone
that drew heat. It was above all a,
well, the refrigerators, I
mean, you couldn't tell the
average housewife living, uh,
wherever, and they're more beyond
someplace and Brittany or wherever, uh,
that the refrigerator wasn't,
uh, uh, uh, a good deal.
But that for the Communist
Party of Frigidaire w fridge,
a Frigo a refrigerator or a Frigidaire,
which is a model,
I don't know if it still is, was,
was only good for making, uh,
ice cubes for fancy, uh, um, uh,
parents teeth where you would drink
American or Scottish American bourbon or
Scotch whiskey. Uh, so,
um, they, um, uh, are gone.
This again, as the communist
poet wrote a Ford Automobile,
the civilization of Detroit,
the assembly line,
the atomic danger in circled by napalm.
Now he said this early on, remembers the
Americans. You use napalm in Vietnam.
It was the Americans. He
use napalm in Vietnam. Um,
here is the symbol of the subjugation
to the dollar applauded even in the land
of Moliere, the Yankee more arrogant at
the nut. Then the Nazi Holocaust. I mean,
this is absurd.
A substitutes to machine for
the poet Coca Cola for poetry,
the Ford for Victor Hugo.
It degenerated to that extent.
Uh, a great sociologist called Edgar
Maha, who is a brilliant book on a,
on a called the red and the white
about it. Brett home village, uh,
he called Reader's digest,
uh,
a pocket size stupa fire
a drug for little minds.
Uh, and he attacked was one of the
earliest to attack from lay the,
and more about that in a while. That is
the absorption of American terms in to,
uh, the French language. Uh, uh,
toothpaste for example,
instead of [inaudible], uh,
flooding the French,
uh, language. But again,
you have to put this in
the context of the Times.
And that's why I guess what his
tour, he has tried to do. 60% of the,
of the people in the communist party
thought the US was readying and aggressive
war. Uh, and almost 95% of people
in the Communist Party, uh,
were against the presence
of us basis in France.
Now remember the guy who got rid of
the U s basis in France was Charles de
Gaulle, who was anything but a communist
who completely opposite of a Communist.
But his view is we'll see,
was that France had to be, uh,
to maintain its status as a great power,
had to be a,
I have a neutral path and influenced
in places where French was spoken
particularly, uh, in, uh, in
west and North Africa. Uh,
and, uh, you know,
in the Middle East and parts in
Lebanon and a of things, uh, like,
um, so, um, there were some, you know,
intellectuals who tried to find a third
way who weren't kind of parroting the
communist party or we're really
going to cow down a Cao Tao.
The way it's our cozy is to,
uh, uh, to, uh, to America, uh,
and, uh, you know, Lamona for example,
which is without question the most
reputable newspaper in France, uh, uh,
though the bay is quite good
too, and a Pluto Mangu. Uh,
but, but it take, it takes,
took a more neutral position,
uh, in, uh, in all of this, uh,
because there were many people
in France who weren't communists.
I thought that the Marshall Plan was a
way of buying off Europe and, uh, and you,
you know, I wasn't, you know,
I was vaguely around in those
days, but, but, you know,
the fear was, you know,
after World War One,
there was a thought that nobody would
ever want another war after World War Two,
and after the, you know, the atomic
bomb. And after the horrors of, of, of,
of, uh, you know, all that had
happened, uh, and the Holocaust, uh,
people were quite certain that there
would be another war. So it was a time of,
of, of great fear. And so
these were big issues, um, in,
in 1952 at the time of the visit of a US
General Matthew Ridgway to take control
of NATO forces, they were huge
demonstrations against United States. Uh,
he was called a butcher in the Korean
War would, would certainly wasn't true.
I was called a war criminal
and that wasn't true either.
But this came at a time when,
uh,
it was the government of a guy who
just died only a couple of years ago.
That'd be about 130 years
old called Antoine Pinay, uh,
who is from Sasha Momoa and you're
a 10, if I remember correctly. And,
and he had been accused of collaboration
during the war and he was in power and
he tried to ludicrous ludicrously enough
break the influence of the [inaudible]
and one of their leaders.
I didn't know about this incident
until I read Kaysville. Uh,
one of the incidents was he accused
Ashoka, do Clo a name you can forget, but,
but it was interesting guy who was
a leader of the Communist Party of,
of being a spy for the Soviets.
And his proof was that they had found
two dead pigeons in the back seat of his
car and an autopsy on the birds,
uh,
that he thought they were a carrier,
pigeons that were smuggling,
going to send secrets off to,
to some Soviet spies
somewhere out of the country.
And of course they did an autopsy
on these birds and they discovered,
I don't know how you do this
to an autopsy. Uh, I didn't
want to be in the room,
but they were not carrier pigeons,
but there were pigeons,
people in France eat pigeons, peas,
you know, and that they simply,
he would have them in his backseat cause
he was going to take home and cook them,
hopefully with lots of garlic
and, and, and the eat them. Uh,
and John Paul Saska,
he said it the same time that if he
had to choose sides in the Cold War,
he would choose, uh, the USSR.
Now Saska like a lots of,
of, uh, of fellow travelers.
We're delusional about what
had happened in Stalin's
Soviet Union. Uh, and, um, his partner,
Simone de Beauvoir,
who's terribly important in the rise
of feminism is feminism as I sure, uh,
uh, you, you know,
she came to the u s in 1947 she had
been in 1947 and she liked the sort of
dynamism of the American economy
and she liked its, it's freedom. Uh,
but she was immediately suspicious of
racism, uh, in the United States. Uh,
and the 1940s in the 1950s as a
in need in our own time. Sadly,
I've though not as much, uh, was
a time of racism. And she said,
so she came right out and said, and that
became a part of the Anti American, uh,
a discourse because when the
Americans would get ahold of her,
and now about how people in
Europe, uh, uh, you know,
treated their minorities
all you had to look to, uh,
all he had to look to the United
States. Uh, where, uh, you know,
I think back my own
childhood when, when, uh, uh,
the freedom three freedom workers were
so brutally murdered in, in Mississippi,
um, and, uh, you know, uh, they would
point, they would point to that.
Um, now what about the role
of Coca Cola and all of this?
I imagine you may have seen Cocacola a
few times in your lives. Um, it became,
it's still is so identified with,
um,
with America and it probably is,
I think it's fair to say the,
the single item that is most identified,
uh,
in the rest of the world with,
uh, w w with the United States,
um,
that you couldn't,
you couldn't talk to people in the,
in the,
in France or anywhere else about baseball.
And you cannot talk to him about hot
dogs though there that this strange thing
emerged in the 1960s called
Lou dog, uh, which are two sir,
miserably, almost frozen, uh,
uh, uh, frankfurters with,
uh, some sort of godawful
cheese put on them and put in,
in what was then the equivalent of a
microwave. But, uh, it was coca cola.
Um, and as you know, the product was, was,
uh, uh, created, I think in the late 18,
1880s. It's very hard to get into.
The Chi's will manage to do it,
to get into the Coca Cola archives for
you might find that recipe. And of course,
I think somebody told me that cocaine was
put originally into the, uh, into coke,
into coke, uh, at, uh, at
the beginning, uh, of it all.
Um, let me give you some examples
how coke and American, uh,
view of itself and view
of the world, um, came to,
came to be.
We will see that every man in uniform
gets a bottle bottle of Coca Cola for 5
cents. Wherever he is. And
whatever it costs, uh, was, uh,
what cocacola had to say about the
relationship between, uh, soldiers, uh,
if they survived the Bataan death
march, uh, and whatever, uh,
and, um, uh, that was, it won.
The Coca Cola actually sent people
as technical as observers, a word,
a phrase.
They used to see where bottling plants
could after the fighting ended, uh,
be set up. Uh, in Europe,
one US soldier wrote a letter
in which he said to my mind,
I'm in this damn mess as much to help
to keep the customer drinking cokes as I
am,
to preserve the million other benefits.
Our country blesses that citizens with
64 bottling plants were set up in Europe,
uh, after, uh, uh, the war, uh, uh,
immediately after the world
was in a couple of years,
they expand to Belgium and,
and, uh, uh, and at
Luke's Ambu and, uh, uh,
the Netherlands in 1947,
I also to Switzerland and Italy
and then to France in 19, uh, 49,
the Olympics of 1950 were held in Finland,
in Helsinki. Uh, and there was not yet,
had not yet been time to
build a Coca Cola plant.
So what they did is they got ahold
of some d day landing vessels,
fill them with Coca Cola.
Uh,
and the Coca Cola company
landed on the shores of Finland,
literally,
uh,
with all of these publicity material
and with 720,000 bottles of Coca Cola.
Now the chairman of, um, um, I didn't know
this either, took highs I castle. Uh, the,
the chairman of Coca Cola was,
was James Farley,
who was a former aid to Franklin
Roosevelt, and that's, he was what?
Very Wa had good contacts.
Um,
and he was a militant anticommunist who
identified the drinking of Coca Cola
with, uh, with democracy. Uh, the,
the Soviets and in their satellite
states did not drink coca cola,
but good old Americans drank a coca cola.
Now you're going to run into huge
lobbies in these countries. In Belgium,
you're gonna run into the beer lobby.
Terribly important in the pay.
You by and Netherlands,
you can run into the beer lobby and in
France you will run a head on to that
lobby. You already know something
about the wine lobby, uh,
which in a way is neither left nor right.
Uh,
but it's neither left nor right. It's
a little more complicated, uh, uh,
there than that. And
they tried to, um, uh,
stir up popular a action
against a Coca Cola.
A communist paper in new in Italy
said that the drinking coke would make
children's hair turn white and therefore,
uh,
you shouldn't do that in Austria,
the communist new biggest
communist newspaper in Vienna,
I wrote that Co cocacola plants
by, uh, by virtue of, of, uh,
the machines they use could be easily
transformed into plant's capable of
turning out nuclear
bombs. Uh, and so, uh, uh,
that good Viennese and good to
Austrians should avoid the insidious,
uh, a numbing a drink. Um,
coke's had begun to arrive in,
in, in France, uh, after war one,
but only in very small numbers
and extremely fancy cafes.
Um, and so, uh,
the Coco Cola having Kaiser would go
into the archives to find all this.
A Coco Cola marketers divided France
into six regions and figured that six,
they should anticipate each person
a drinking six. Coca-Cola's, uh, uh,
per year. Uh, the problem is
that foreign investments, uh,
such as, uh, building plants required, uh,
the permission of the Ministry
of, uh, of, of finance, uh,
and, um, that, uh, all
of this anxiety, uh,
comes along the Minister of finance,
Ministry of Finance gets involved, uh,
and all of this business, uh, the debate,
uh, reaches the Chamber of Deputies, uh,
in 1950s.
Uh,
and also this merges with other fears of
other American products. A John Deere.
Uh, some of you may be from
Illinois and that we're,
John Deere is made the
tractors and all that.
And that is by far the biggest company,
a successful company in, in, uh,
marketing machinery that's been part
of the French agricultural revolution,
a sense a World War II.
But of course,
the little producers and France
were against John Deere as well.
It also comes at a time, as you know, of,
of, uh, of a widespread outrage or of,
of intellectuals and filmmakers against
the Hollywood is nation of French, uh,
uh, of a, a French movie theaters.
And because France is idea,
attitudes towards own movies has always
been that as its attitudes towards
almost all industrial production that
France makes these fine little products of
quality. Uh, and the
arrival of, of, of the, uh,
God forbid the Charlton
Heston's of the world and, and,
and John Wayne and all of this stuff.
Uh, so these debates are going on, uh,
uh, among intellectuals and, and, and it,
film watchers, et Cetera. Uh, you know,
I mean, these debates just go on
and on. I mean, there are radio,
radio stations in France
now, um, have to, uh, uh,
play a certain percentage of French
music as opposed to Bruce Springsteen and
the stones and, and, and whatever.
They have to have a certain percentage.
And so there is this still this,
this paranoia that, that, uh, uh,
that English or French music
or other kinds of music coming,
we'll wipe out a wipe out
what's left of, of, of, uh,
of the French music industry and,
and that, uh, people won't put,
won't play as Jacques Brel
anymore or a Georgia, uh, or they,
they owe a few hey, or a Johnny, uh,
Johnny Holy Day, who was, anyway,
he was born, born Belgian, Belgian,
and he has his own problems,
whether it's nothing to do
with it. Um, but yet when a,
there are these, um, you know,
there are these debates, uh,
it seemed like the ties between coke and
the US government were even stronger.
Cocacola demanded that the US State
Department intervene in some way to stop
kind of uprising against
the rival of Coca Cola. Um,
US papers, uh, went, uh, went wild.
Cocacola was not injurious to the health
of American soldiers who liberated
France from the Nazis so that communist
deputies could sit in session today was
one,
a editorial in a US paper.
You can't spread the doctrines of
Mark's among people who drink coca cola.
The dark principles of revolution in a
rising proletariat may be expounded over
a bottle of vodka on a scarred table,
you know,
such as mores or some place like that,
or even a bottle of brandy.
But as utter Lee,
fantastic to imagine two men stepping
to a Soda Fountain and ordering a couple
of cokes in which to toast the
downfall of their capitalist Oh,
uh, oppressors. Uh, and
so, um, uh, so it went,
but coca cola arrived in France,
had got a permission to
be produced in France, uh,
and to be drunk in France and still is,
uh,
though often by American
tourists and France,
I have been on several occasions in a
really good, in one case even great.
Uh, and this is not dissing
Americans. They forgive me, uh, eh,
great restaurants and seeing
Americans ordering Cocacola, uh,
with their four or five course meal.
And that does make me sad. Does
it make me sound like a snob? Uh,
Eh, I've seen people drink milk
to and things like that. Uh, uh,
anyway, what can, what can
we say? I shouldn't get so
involved in all this stuff.
How did people like Coca Cola,
a pole, a sewn dodge, you know,
the French take take two American polls.
I mean, do these polls all the time.
I saw dodge is the word for Paul.
Uh, in 1953 said it only 70%.
People who drank it liked it and 60%,
not at all.
And the other ones couldn't
remember because they'd gone
into something else. Uh,
drinking something else I guess.
Um, but the dikes began to,
began to break and millions of, of,
of cokes, uh, are, um, you know,
are sold every year in France as, as
everywhere. Now this is just an aside,
but this is the same case.
Um, you know, as an Africa,
the debates and not been the same.
But one of the interesting things,
and I think sad things about,
uh, the places I know in
Africa, which has very few,
uh, but our family members are new Africa
about pretty well, uh, is that, you know,
the, the, the, the domination of, of, of
coke, uh, particularly in places you know,
that are Muslim and which people
don't drink alcoholic beverages,
the domination of coke and
Fanta, uh, uh, which are very,
very expensive for, for people
who have almost no money, uh,
and that the front tire or is sort of
becomes the equivalent of a celebration of
with champagne in France or the United
States or someplace where people,
where people drank.
And so some of the same issues,
some of the same debates are there. Uh,
and these companies just make Zillions,
uh, uh, off the strengths. And I'm
not criticizing these companies, am I,
I guess I don't know.
But anyway.
Now let's talk about some of the other
aspects of Anti Americanism before, uh,
you know, I end in the, in in 15 minutes
or so with, um, uh, the obvious ones,
uh, uh, today. Um,
well architecture, uh, for example, um,
many of the debates about preservation,
about keeping Paris what Ga,
anywhere you want to name the
beautiful centers, straws,
Bu the way they've always
been, uh, have involved, uh,
fighting against, uh, the
skyscraper ization if you will.
The got Seattle,
they got Seattle,
the skyscrapers in
France in the late 1960s.
There was a huge debate over the tour
Montparnasse and the tour Montparnasse uh,
uh, it right on. It's right on the,
it's where the station and wall
Pranassa is in Paris. It's right on the,
on the right beyond the
boulevard. Montparnasse there, uh,
was built with the enthusiastic
a cooperation if not no
money in the pockets of,
as yours a pump you do. Uh, the
president of France who said,
we must renounce this outmoded aesthetic.
That's an exact quote.
And so the big battle over
the Tour de France, which is
a year, I get my own view,
but it gives a, it was a
hideous building that, that,
that debt debt, uh, you know,
is a blight on the skyline of Paris.
Uh,
and if it said,
the only thing good about it is you can't
see it when you're viewing Paris from
the top and they have an elevator that
shoots up at the top and it destroyed, uh,
you know, while, anyway, you
know, what, what can we say?
It's an obvious thing now,
people that defended the tour more, which
is identified with Chicago, Eh, you know,
and the skyscrapers, I would say, well,
look, when people criticize the, the,
the Arctic,
the two,
and he failed the Eiffel Tower
when it was built in 1888 and 1889.
And Zola was among those who sign
saying, this is awful. It must go.
And it is part of what people go to
see. Now. People do not go see the tour.
Montparnasse because of the Eiffel
Tower, you know, uh, represented, uh,
uh, changes in, in, you know,
in industry and steel and iron and
all this stuff. And the tour mark,
we'll Parnoss I just represents a kind
of an American approach to architecture
that,
that the traditionalist a found wanting.
And so what they did subsequently
is they don't lie, they false,
which is outside of Paris. But what you
can see it if you stand, for example,
in the tweets are three,
uh, or you know, um,
around there you can see it
beyond the Arc de Triomphe.
And that's where lots of businesses,
that's the kind of Americanization of, of,
of French architecture and business.
Uh, but generally the, the, the, the,
the friendship and very good of,
of,
of trying to protect Paris from the
planners who would destroy other way the
place looks with an Americanized
kind of architecture. There.
There've been other problems
too. I mean, the, the, the,
the construction said at plus
digitally me and you know, the,
the tour Montparnasse became the
most famous and appropriately enough,
these kinds of battles,
uh,
to protect Paris against this kind of
architecture. Have involved the far right,
uh, conservative, right? Not
the first show of the fascist,
right. But the far right,
like my late friend Louis Shovel,
a very conservative man,
was the greatest historian of Paris. Uh,
and, and, uh, or my Fred Francois Louie,
who is now head of the committee to
preserve old Paris with people on,
I'm the last, you know, that the sort
of the French equivalent of me, uh, uh,
against the center against the kind of
plant plan air who just want to make, uh,
uh, make money. Um, but you know, other
aspects of Americanization, you know, the,
the word Pavio in France, uh, you know,
people wanted to have
their houses, uh, uh,
in the prosperous suburbs if
best at [inaudible], for example,
uh, most of the suburbs, you know, at the
time we're talking about until 1945 are,
are, are, are miserable places,
but the people in Sacramento,
La and the west of Paris or
Versailles, uh, you know what?
They want to have their [inaudible],
which was a big kind of modern
Americanized House with all these things,
you know, cell phones, refrigerators, all
this business, swimming pools and lawns.
What could be more American
American than lawns. Now,
the vast majority of the people who
live in the Asian region do not live in
houses.
They live in apartments.
And the vast majority live in buildings
that they do not own or not the vast
majority, but the majority do. But
that became a big, uh, a big issue.
The television, the television,
uh, you know, people, uh,
thought to television
would destroy France.
I used to say that when Charles
the gold died, finally Columbian,
they do the leaves. Uh, he died of
board and watching French TV, uh,
because French TV,
which has some of the best stuff around,
but also has some of the worst, uh,
this talk shows and go on and on and on.
It's just, this is
numbing. Uh, but also, uh,
they took all these things that I've
never watched in my life. Like Dallas,
I used to be a big show and all these
things, I have no idea what they are,
but they, but people will, even
our, you know, a very dear friends,
you go there and they're
watching this stuff and well,
I'm the TV's not just American,
but, but the, that whole, you know,
that kind of culture was identified with
America and intellectuals didn't like
that very much.
People should be reading books and
they should be reading books too.
But who am I to say? I mean,
I watch ESPN, you know,
hours every day and every game of it's on.
So I can't really say,
I don't watch TV. I'm closing.
It used to be, you know,
when the first years and years,
and then I was living in
France and went to France,
you could tell who was an American in
about one second by looking at their feet.
Now I don't spend a lot of time
looking at people's feet. Uh,
but you could tell the way they look
because they were tennis shoes and tennis
shoes now are called a
bus get, you know, uh, uh,
but now everybody wears
the same way in jeans,
the same thing because there weren't
jeans in France and now everybody wears
jeans. Uh, I can still tell who's
American who isn't usually, but uh,
but the clothing was identified with,
with,
with America was seen as
being somehow an on French.
And of course there's the big war between,
uh, France, you know, hi, accrue to him,
you know, of, of French fashion and
trying to preserve as Milan tries to also,
and they've been very successful at that.
But clothing was one thing, uh, as well.
Uh, you hold these knee, what can
one say, but you hold these knee,
somebody called it a
cultural share. Nuba. Uh,
I share new blue was the big nuclear
plant, uh, that blew up in, in Kiev.
Uh, and, uh, and certainly the idea of a,
of a Mickey mouse and goofy and
all of these people, uh, you know,
and you go and you've spent, I
haven't, I've never been there.
I would never walk into place.
She's been Saint Columbo. You spent,
what's a 50 euro to
get in and, and uh, uh,
so your kids can get sick eating
American coffee, a cotton candy. Uh,
but again, people go over the top
or Mcdonald's. Ha Ha. Ah, uh, I,
Mcdonald's would start it in France.
I really, in the, in the 80s,
Burger kicking tried and failed.
Now Mcdonald's is a big issue
and she was able value came, uh,
to Yale a couple of years ago.
She was able bay as a guy who now you
became identified with the struggle
against Mcdonald's.
Uh,
he was actually lived two years
in la though he speaks to me.
I wasn't here when he came.
My daughter,
I was a translator forum and introduced
him and all that. But, uh, he,
but he's one who led the struggle,
uh, uh, to try to, first of all,
to preserve his part of the Avp
of law. Uh, Laura, Zack against,
uh, uh, making a strafing
practice range for the,
for the French air force and has gone
after a Mcdonald's is representing the
globalization that's going to
hurt, um, a local commerce.
Then Mcdonald's has tried
to compromise in some ways.
If you go and get a Mcdonald's,
and I won't go into places,
I shouldn't say that because the
recording this, but, but, uh,
I haven't been in years in
France, but the, uh, you know,
they had these little
salads with a little,
a few pieces of goat's cheese in it to
go along with it. The 2 million calorie,
uh, uh, a burger, uh, and all
that. But what a joy they will,
they did is that he and his
friends went up and broke up. Uh,
it didn't hurt anybody, but they'd sort
of trashed a I Mcdonald's in, um, uh,
in meal, which is an Av, you hone the
south right near this huge, huge bridge,
the biggest span bridge.
And, uh, in Europe.
And of course he went on trial and
he became a presidential candidate.
And I guess I get my daughter stays
there. Really great guy. Uh, but, uh, uh,
you know, Mcdonald's became, he became an
issue, but, and this, and I said, well,
maybe it won't work,
but Mcdonald's,
because you can eat cheaply there because
everything's so expensive. And France,
so expensive.
Uh,
they're always just where you could
drive by is when an overnight, you know,
there's one everywhere. Uh,
they are always full of,
of people eating whatever
it is they eat there.
So it became a symbol more important than
the reality. Makoto Makoto [inaudible],
uh, became, uh, became a symbol
of, of, uh, of globalization,
first of Americanization and then a
globalization. Uh, and then, you know,
what comes along now, but Starbucks,
there's, there's three or four,
there's one in Monterrey, in, in, in
Paris. Uh, there's one I saw in, um,
a summer up open.
Huh.
And there are a couple other ones there
and they soon will be everywhere and
even eat better Mount Shay supermarkets.
Now,
people don't dispute supermarkets anymore,
but they used to.
The big ones are the [inaudible] and
all these look there, it's probably the,
the biggest, uh, and I mean the
upscale version of [inaudible].
Now I remember in the 1970s of people
thought the supermarkets were just
terrible things. Why? Because
they were going to end,
did destroy local commerce that most
villages now do not have the little
[inaudible] that grocery store that,
uh,
made it possible for old ladies
to just to walk a few, uh,
equivalent of a few hundred
meters to buy their milk. Uh,
and now they can't do that anymore.
Now there's more than just a
disappearance of a way of buying food.
It's the way it's a disappearance of a
place where you get together and exchange
news in the morning.
Our grocery store disappeared about
10 years ago or about eight years ago
because everybody goes to the
Supermart Shea, uh, EPR, Ma
supermom chasing them, um,
shows, uh, though, um,
the other thing that it could attack but
ha ha could interfere with and has not
as much as we feared were markets. The
Saturday market, the Wednesday market,
that Saturday and Wednesday
market, depending on the
size of the town, uh, that,
that are all over France.
And in fact, people still,
even to even young people your age still
have a sense that you got to protect.
You've got to save the markets, and you've
got other people that produce there,
I mean, that bring what they
produce in their fields.
They're, uh, by goat's cheese,
Pico doll, uh, you know, whatever
wine, uh, from producers directly.
And that's part of the ambulance.
That's what's great about living in France
or living in Germany or living in pay
by or living anywhere in
Belgium, in Belgium. And,
and so many people will go and guided
by the big things of milk and, and,
uh, uh, you know, uh,
the big items of paper
towels and all that,
but then they will still go to the market,
not just for a trip of nostalgia,
uh,
but because the products they know they're
buying from people they know and all
that.
So that fear was probably turned out to
be less than a one had a worried about.
Um,
and then of course,
there's the question of
from lay every about,
oh, maybe five or six, seven years,
somebody in and in one of the
ministries gets it into his or her head.
That framed lais has to, uh, you know,
has to disappear from the vocabulary,
the official vocabulary,
the administrative vocabulary
of France from, uh,
is the absorption into a daily
parlance of words that are,
uh,
non-French of which it was the
first one that really took over,
uh, at least in my memory was Lou
weekend. And there were attempts,
I think, energy scale this time. And
there's one even more recently, um,
under early stages of [inaudible], uh, uh,
presidency to a stem stern
circulars around saying,
in a correspondence,
you shall not use Lou weekend,
but you'd rather use the fat, the Lhasa
men, the end of the, well, I mean,
that lasted about a matter of days,
uh,
because that's simply not
terribly a practical, uh,
English words began to permeate,
uh, with a sort of chic,
uh, uh, chic, a sense of being cool. Uh,
the French language drug store,
I can remember,
remember around penalty
San Angelo [inaudible],
Sasha map the metro there on thoughts
right across there was Lou drug store and
it was, it was a pharmacy. It had had
your basic green flashing light thing.
It's a pharmacy,
but they also sold all sorts of things.
So it was almost like a anticipating a,
a a supermarket.
And the term was low drug stock.
Uh, it wasn't a union pharmacy,
it was La Pharmacy,
it was Lou drug store.
And people debated that you could
go on and on about this. Um,
I'll just give you a couple of examples.
I mean, these are obvious ones.
I just wrote them down because they're,
because they're obvious,
but I pray ugly sweaters,
sweater with the, there was, he,
they fully fashioned, uh,
uh, [inaudible] uh, uh,
new. Say Smith. S. M. A. R. T a what?
A virtual shopping club. Uh,
Lavati tabla wash and wear.
Uh, they, they drink, they Zhong, Rafi Ne,
the drink of people who are refined. Now,
this had already started to happen in
the night and the 1890s with certain
terms. As I suggested round,
you're talking about I meet re, uh,
they began to into the long drink. For
example, they began infiltrate the, uh,
the French, uh, language. Uh,
the hot dog became the chef show,
uh,
in these times of these
various commands. But, but, uh,
basically with the global,
with globalization and
with the American cultural,
uh, uh, a dominance, uh,
these attempts are, uh,
are basically just putting a,
uh,
small fingers in very large dykes.
Why did it matter so much?
All of this is because Francis no
longer a great power. Uh, and it's,
uh, and, uh, intellectuals and lots
of other people, uh, in France,
including me, are determined, uh,
that French culture, uh, retain. Uh,
it's, it's place in the world.
And, uh, I am chronically,
uh, sad to see another supermarket go up
where they're already been. Two of them.
Uh, it saddens me terribly,
uh, to, uh, you know,
see the Golden Arches,
uh, almost everywhere now.
Uh, a subway, which is a chain that
have actually happened at like a lot.
Uh, and those, those are, uh,
becoming, uh, all over the place. Uh,
so you're fighting against the waves
that cannot be, um, uh, they cannot,
cannot be halted.
Uh,
but in a way may not be
all a very bad thing.
So long as a sense of
perspective is maintained,
and that often was not maintained
in the early days of the,
almost hysterical a battle against,
uh,
the mounting empire of Coca Cola.
Have a wonderful Thanksgiving
vacation. See You, uh,
see you next time and go blue.